every so often i don't know how we do it
but we here at late night we get stars
and i mean big stars from the world of
entertainment to sit down and share some
of their innermost secrets with us
and uh and then this is stuff that the
tabloids don't have
and then we reveal it here and then it's
in the tabloids because we're always
first well tonight we have a really
famous music star who for some reason
was willing to spill his guts for us on
camera this is some pretty dark
disturbing stuff you might want to send
the kids out of the room take a look
bowie
secrets
sometimes
when i'm at a mcdonald's
i wait until nobody's looking
and then i stick my hand inside the
straw dispenser
and touch all the straws
secrets
i've reinvented my image so many times
that
i'm in denial that i was originally an
overweight korean woman
secrets
i was on tour in the united states back
in 89
and we did a show in cincinnati
during that show i shouted out
it's great to be in cincinnati
that was a lie
in the original version of space oddity
i sang
ground control i miss my mum
ground control
i miss my mum
what can i say
i miss mum
secrets
you'd think that being a famous rock
star
married to a supermodel
would be one of the greatest things in
the world
it is
secrets
i don't know how many times someone has
come up to me and said
hey let's dance
i hate dancing
god it's stupid
bowie
[Applause]
what a man of mystery